I've like. Twenty four. You know three.
Years.
I don't think there ever will be or perhaps
needs to be another name investable
but it
but it's interesting to speculate i think
the two thousand will obviously be a
momentous time you know
and not not too often do you live
through the change of a millennium.
But it'll be a momentous time for australia
because it does represent the you know
rescinding the federation
and as all the point is after a time to
australia to look to you know to what its
future is going to be in the 21st
century but it's interesting i think
that the celebrations that
do happen and i'm convinced
that there'll be fairly interesting
celebrations whether the weather wave hosting
the olympics in the year 2000 or not i
think not exactly relevant but i think
that the celebrations will happen anyway.
But i think it will be very much about.
Seeing that changed role
and i mean who knows there's another sort
of you know seven eight years and all
that time too and how what shifts
australia augusta and that point of time.
I'm not sure but i was not sure i would
call that another nimbin i think that.
What
that celebrations is going to be about is
really estradiol having arrived in southeast
asia and. And having grown up and matured.
And i think now we all find that very
exciting i mean and i think that.
Not too many people probably i people
will argue with that. The forms of it.
I don't think too many people
really argue with the fact
that australia is now standing on its own
two feet in this part of the world. And.
I guess the other the other
difference with that is
that nimbin was very much about a section
of australia celebrating it was if you
like the.
What i sometimes call the sensitive antenna
in the horns of a rhinoceros it was the
sort of people who had their head
up and after sort of realised
that the changes were happening and bob
dylan's line something's happening
but you don't know what
it is the mr james.
It wasn't the whole of
australia celebrating.
I think then in a sense in the bicentenary
this step was a much more general
celebration lay there were people
rightly saying that you know
that there were certain
things in australia
that we you know had to think very
much about what we were celebrating
and why to me the word celebrate as an act
of verb i mean it always it always beats
a question celebrate what and
why celebrate and if you apply
that to the 2000 what it leads you into
is is some pretty deep thinking about you
know your framework in
your culture and i think
that. My hope for the year 2000.
It is if there is a celebration it will
be in australia wide celebration abused
and celebration that all australians
can take part in and for
that to be a valid celebration i think it
will have to come to terms finally with
the aboriginal issue
and i think there are any simple
answers to the aboriginal question
but if if we haven't managed to at least
come to terms with the treaty in some
better understanding of aboriginal
australia by the year 2000 and i think
that you know. We can't really have
a valid celebration of australia.
So i think that will be one dimension.
And then the other dimension will be.
Where we do stand in
relation to southeast asia.
I mean the image in my mind of a celebration
for the year 2000 as one with a kind
of you know balinese galleons over there
and singaporean line
dancers they were there
and laying puppets from indonesia
over there and you know as.
Celebration
that acknowledges our place in the world
not an arts festival of largely european
and american culture sort of you know
transplanted to this play a part of the world
and one might ask why our festival stay
there really reflect reflect that.
How will be more than they do but i
think the times are coming and i think
that you know the celebrations of australia
in the year 2000 are very likely i
think that i'm guessing here but in the you
know. Seven or eight years in between.
I think that'll be the dimension.
We've sort of starting to
realize in grapple distantly
and intellectually with the fact
that we're part of southeast asia
but we're not grappling with that. Yet in
terms of what does this mean culturally.
I mean you know we still really expect
asians i think to learn our language
and learn our ways in
fact i mean relate to us.
That's like we haven't there nearly
enough of you know going in learning the
language and learning their ways
and then exploring the culture
and as i say i don't just
mean that aunts and.
In the food and the music but i mean
exploring the realities and i think
that that's if the if there
are any valid dimensions to.
The celebration in the year 2000. Maybe
that is the name the new the year 2000.
I don't know.
I don't get frustrated
with very much anymore.
It's perhaps because my expectations.
My expectations so changed
and also because. I think.
In terms of in terms of the pace of this
change i mean whether whether i don't
really get get frustrated with
that i guess because i've arrived
at a point where are not.
I think it istiklal enough anymore.
I think i was when i was younger
i think that i have the answers.
I mean i think we're all grappling with
all these questions at many levels.
All of the time and i don't have any
medical answers for any of these things
and i don't think you know my health.
Either so
that the change will always be sort of you
know you know three steps forward here
and two steps back where i don't really
get frustrated by it anymore i just see
that the process is what's
interesting about it.
I enjoy the process and
or mostly joy into i mean i am one less
fortunate people i love what i do.
I mean organising celebrations if no
one was prepared to pay me to do it.
It's to do it. I think it's the most enjoyable
thing to do that. I possibly could.
Doing so i enjoy that the process enormously.
I don't always enjoy the product.
If some celebration sort of
please me more than others
but i don't think i get frustrated
by it. I guess sometimes i just.
And i guess the nice thing about. About my
current situation is that it's cyclical.
I mean once dealing with a
program of celebrations
and events through the if it doesn't
happen one year the way quite alike
or the way you want to put it
aside and go back to it next year
and i think we're finally
i mean my satisfaction is
that i think we are finally
creating an australian culture.
We're finally creating those sort of landmarks
i member graeme dunstan sort of you
know saying at one stage that
that his measure of a celebration
was whether it was something
that you measured your life by in
terms of people say look you know.
Sue and ted got married before
this this into the bicentenary
or our laden had a baby you know.
Afternoon
and so once celebrations become sort of
part of the measuring yardsticks of your
life you know you've arrived and and
once celebrations become a kind of.
A calendar that people people accept
and that's what that's what i've
always been striving to do to try
and bring outdoor celebration in.
Events to the point where people sort
of accept that it's part of their lives
and there's a few
that i think we always as i mean new year's
eve in australia for as long as i can
remember back to
when i was a kid was always special you
didn't consider going to be before me the
news you stray lived to
be in a social situation
and to be there was a sense of the sun
finally importance about this day
that made you want to be
part of where it was a party
or whether it was a sort of you
know a celebration of fireworks
and a thousand people
and having abba think
that two years ago we had
something a 400000 people.
It is a without any advertising
opperman just a herd instinct
that people want to be together.
I've always rather admired
and vince like the envious of
asian cultures which which have
that almost into them.
I mean i'm a member spinning a bit
of time afternoon when i went back
and spent some times of the bowels of
bengal up in central been y'all and
and it traveled for about three months
through the indian villages with them
and i member very clearly that you
would wake up on a certain day and.
Nobody needed to announce it or
tell you just everybody knew that
that day was a celebration day and
there was no thought of going off
and healing the rice fields that this.
On this day everyone sort of you know took
their plates of fireable sugared sweets.
Went down to the river and.
And in fact i if there was ever an
experience in my life anywhere else.
Close to christ and him
and. I went with that.
Of the bowels to a celebration in
central bengal called the milat.
When they came over to nim and they
looked around the set up is a meal
that we know. So when i went over to
bengal they put me to this meal that was
that was held on the banks of
the ganges in this little town
and it would i think it was something
like kind of 2000 years every year this
miller had been held
and it was all determined by the moon phases
in the calendar so bowels right across
bengal no one.
Need to sort of you know to
put up posters or to announce
that this mailer was held on this state.
Everybody just knew i mean because that
was the moon cycle this was the date
when it was always help and
it it always been held.
You know for you know for centuries
and this spot by the river
and these ancient ancient trees were always
the spot where purcell so i went with
this. Person
and asked by all in his touring party here
the way the way it work was very tribal
i mean certain people kind of
you know went and played host
and then sort of their whole kind
of tribal structure would arrive
and they would look after them
and feed them and entertain.
So we're a fairly we write about
a week before this thing and
and we've been travelling by car
and whatever you know if it.
Hours and hours and finally got
to this partner stable we're here
and then said you mean it was nothing.
Well it was was a sort of you know a bit
of riverbank sort of you know on the edge
of this sandy desert and there was nothing
that the eye could see for
miles in any direction.
So we pitched camp
and sure enough over the next ten days
you'd see these figures on the horizon.
I mean many people would walk at this
thing inwardly find sort of you know four
weeks before so i could walk to it.
You just see these figures
slowly coming over the horizon.
It might take three or four hours so
when you first potted them to
act they got close enough that
that you could actually make
out any of their features
and then slowly over this
sort of you know week
or 10 days just these thousands i don't
know how many people came to this ng
hundred thousand probably over these days
you know as tens of thousand people to
slowly kind of roll in
an oxcart sort on foot.
You know one of the few groups
that can by car. I might add.
And just all around me. There's a
wonderful festival sort of took place.
You know people sort of you know brought
things bundles under their arms
and sort of you know.
Things in little carts and sort of all
these little little city sprang up
and wonderful concerts happened
and wonderful banquets were held
and then sort of you know the moon
phase signal that it's time for.
Me allowed to end and just as quickly as
that it all happened everything packed up
and everyone knew so these little figures
taking four hours to disappear on the
horizon and we actually stayed until
after the whole thing was over
and it went right back to being this saintly
bank with nothing visible for miles in
any direction and it's
that sort of thing i've always kind of a
say in mean admired you know what a pity
we don't live in a situation that has
that sort of the pin and instinct
and understanding and what a pity
celebration isn't so much part of our lives
that it's a step as in that you know
arguable i'm questioning sort of way
but i think slowly that is happening.
So the australians are creating a
celebrations calendar for themselves.
And funnily enough it's come out of
celebrations i mean i don't think we're
particularly spiritual
or religious country
but i mean it has sort of it has picked
up sort of you know traditions like
christmas and whatever
but i don't think it's necessarily for
quick greatly religious reasons but
but they are becoming
very real celebrations.
We do a christmas pageant down here
each year that has a cast of thousands
and sort of you know as many people turn
up to it as we can possibly sort of you
know feed into the place
and it's interesting seeing these traditions
growing it's got to the point where
you know people make their own costumes
and so there's a communications network
but i think if we almost if we stopped
organizing it would happen but the court
and i feel
that that's that's that's sort of was one
of the cheap ones of nimbin actually
that i mean you know.
This 10 day festival happened
it took quite a lead up
and not 20 years later there's a community
of people around there still celebrating
it.
It's rather interesting talking to a younger
generation now because they have no idea.
I mean it's sort of nimbin the
name invest or came out of nowhere
and went to nowhere as far as our concern
in fact one other interesting story
that i quite often tell in
and one of my trips up to nimbin which was
a train trip on the overnight sort of.
No wasn't express up to lismore. I got on.
Onto the train and sat
down in this carriage
and they were sort of
they were sort of eight
or ten young teenagers sitting
for five yards away from me
and one of them was telling this story about
how our course he was he was slightly
older and so he was sort of you know.
Telling the ropes in this story about
how to suddenly on one weekend.
All of these thousands of hippies from all
over the country decide they'd somehow
got this mysterious signal and it
all up and converged on nimbin.
And i remember thinking if
only it was that simple.
If only they were this mysterious
that just sort of do people
like them sort of magnet
and felt like sort of saying hey do you
realize the sort of the hundreds of people
who put countless hours
of thought now let it go.
But if a young male here i'm young. Sheldon.
But i think it's quite interesting.
I mean i think that. The
younger generation that nimbin
that doesn't mean strange not very good
at preserving its own cultural history.
I always feel.
I mean partly because we're dominated by
what dylan thomas called the barrier of a
common language if we didn't speak
english or american be a lot easier
but because so many of our cultural are
artifacts of been you know american films
and american cartoons and idea
over the years and british
but more recently american we
lose our own cultural history.
I mean the people in the 30s i mean most
australians of a certain age in a certain
you if you mention sort of you know.
American figures like
ensberg or barrios or.
Or you know the.
John cage or you know that the great
musical figures or at figures they would
and i talking about but mention similar
innovators from australia from.
The thirties.
You know it's most people know you're
talking about we're just we haven't kept
their own cultural history
and i think that's continued you know
pretty much this that's getting better.
But i think that i mean i actually used to
always think in the years after nimbin.
A store always think you know nimbleness
probably a pale reflection of what
happened in. In america in europe
and you know what what a pity i
wasn't in san francisco doing a spear
and missed all that because i never travel
overseas before then and in 19. Seventy.
Seventy six. I finally scraped
a few dollars together
and did my pilgrimage went off
and sort of you know spent the
year traveling through the states
and traveling three of and
visiting a lot of these places
that had been reading about them
and been inspirational to me
and meeting meeting people who'd
been inspirational and went off
and spent some time at
the tennessee found.
Stephen gaskin and sort of went off the
fin door and spent some time at vinton
and you know countless other kind
of you know cultural makers.
New age movement and you know i sat there
and talked with countless people
about woodstock etc. Etc.
and Came to a conclusion over a period
that you know what had
happened in australia.
You know was by no means making in
fact sounded to me a jolly sight more
interesting in many ways
than than than things
that i had thought were you know perhaps
were much better than they were
but the skill is i mean we never got around
to making nimbin the movie people got
around to making woodstock the movie
and i think that's the difference we haven't
so perhaps that's a good thing i guess
for that reason our cultural tradition
probably hasn't been is distorted
and exaggerated that we're also sort of
you know perhaps in danger of losing it
and i think it's probably only fairly
recently the younger generation is starting
to look past that and i think a
lot of the a lot of the prob..
Ms in the country love the fact
that we don't appreciate the aboriginal
background and the aboriginal heritage
that have to do with the fact
that we we've looked at our culture through
the filter of the first edition you pay
in and then american culture
and that's why i think
that cultural shift is so important
that we're seeing australia
and its own terms and i think
there will probably come a time
when we start researching all of that and
digging it out and saying well okay.
Not only how did the
nimbin festival happen
but you know what was the stray lee of the
30s like what were the sort of you know
that the radical movements in
the afternoons and either.
And i thought i think we
we undervalue theirs.
So it may well be that
some some teacher point
that same teenager travelling up in
the chain to lismore abc won't be so
divinely unconscious of how all these
things happen because the other side of it.
I think is it's important to appreciate
how they do happen. I mean you know.
For my experience.
Nothing in i'm talking here about
the area celebrations and events.
The better organised they are. The more
they look as a they happen just by magique.
But i have never seen a substantial of
event in western countries at least that's
that's worked very well with where there
hasn't been enormous planning in energy
and detail and whatever it's got into it
and i think it's probably pretty important
for people to you know to realise
that that's that that's what makes i
mean that the vision and the spirit
and whatever all important but so is
the sort of answer metaphore for life.
I suppose so is the getting down to the tin
tacks of it you know how is this going
to happen. One of the mechanics
was actually quite interesting.
I mean in 1980 so you know end up
and participated in a 10
year anniversary festival at
that nimbin by virtue if you
people really happened.
Saying over 10 years are up me saying so.
No i'm saying well what we do about it.
And that happened. The experience
was interesting i mean.
I tried to go back
and repeat a little bit the pattern
of 173 went up there at easter time
and sort of announced
that we were going to sort of hold a
festival creation workshop we were going to
sort of invite anyone.
Everyone to come along
and talk about what this what this
anniversary festival is going to be so we
ensconced ourselves in
that effect out there
and sort of you know
over a couple of days.
I mean loads of people hundreds of people
probably came through all terribly
concerned to talk about whether this was
going to be about environmental women
or aborigines. And i
thought oh good you know
when we get all this out of the way
when we're you know where
we've cleared the air
when we know why we're all doing it
then we can actually start planning.
To my dismay was a one sided
cleared all and decided
that they actually drew up a real sort
of list that's going to be about these
things and then a size icons that was it.
No one was left sitting i
think you know at the next.
How do we how do we dig this year tells i
how do we organize the food supply lines
all of the things that that are basically
that did x steps i take a
rather prosaic view of it but
that was i think we.
One of the the things that
struck me from that period was
that we've we've produced a fairly
intellectual place for generation that's in a
sense over educated i think i mean with
with so many of us have been through
university and so you know good it
conceptual thinking in theorizing
that we can think out of all these issues
that when it. There's not a lot of.
A real basic sort of hands on
practical skilling the end.
Perhaps
and that's critique of the education system
i suppose in a diss in indecent teaching
people how to think conceptual.
We probably need to be thinking in
celebrations we need to be thinking about
teaching. Well how you do it and i don't
see a lot of a lot of that happening.
I suppose these days it's harder in
the period that led up to newman and
when i talked earlier about some of
the things of starting rock venues
and what it was a bit of a simpler society
in those days i mean if you were only 19
and you only had a couple of
hundred dollars to your name.
If you were lucky you could actually go
and pay the first the first month's rent
on a building in you could actually sort
of you know grab a sound system strap a
stage in and start of a new these days.
This is feeling that everything
has become so super professional
that it's all you know an issue got
backers and finance and lawyers
and you know you can't do anything and i
think that's a bit sad because i think
that part of that spirit of an
emblem was there and we can do it.
Spirit that you know that it's not
only in their ends of the entrepeneurs
and and.
The moneyed the money part of town
but if you can conceive anything strong
enough you can do it and i must admit
when we think back to how naively we
stepped into some of those things.
It was naive but carried off as i said
the bottom line is that nobody started.
Nobody died and you know and perhaps.
As we have now i think what's happened is
that the societies becoming
increasingly specialized and.
An increasingly professionalized
and maybe that's a good thing
but i think with the young people.
I think we're probably reaching another
one of those watersheds if we're not
careful. We're going to go
right back to where we were
when i came in in the 50s that that
that things are run by these
older generation that has
or all of the finance thus all of
the power and all of the strings
and the younger generation that doesn't
have a lot of power over their own lives
and their own decision making.
I mean obviously there are young people
that that come crashing through all that
and and do fantastic things but i think.
These harder and i think
it's one of the things that.
We're going to have to come to
terms with i mean sometimes i feel
that we were closer 20 years ago to coming
to terms with some of those things.
I mean i think we all realized then
although we realized intellectually
that there wasn't going
to be work for everyone
that we were going to
increasingly have machines
and computers do it then we're going
to have to not have to the joy was
that we were going to arrive at a
society where people work less
and had more leisure and
we haven't achieved
that we seem to arrive at the society
where one group of the population works
harder than than is you know particularly.
Desirable for people to work
and of the whole bunch of the population
is alienated and has no access to that
and sits on their bum. So we haven't
achieved the right balance and.
I'm not sure we have.
We've achieved there out.
The right balance of power are there.
Because that's come back to power.
I mean i think we've disenfranchised lots
of groups in the not only their regionals
way in danger of disenfranchising
young people in this city.
And all sorts of other groups. So i think
we have to grapple with those things and.
I think that i hope there's a role
there for us the celebrations
and i hope there's a ralph and in that
i mean even seems to me to become now.
Both a set of ideas.
And a mental spiritual community
as much as a physical community.
I mean i know lots of people that
don't physically live it and in
that actually seen him in the nimbin
community is some importance to be liars
and i hope in the air that.
Some of that exploring
and radical thinking
and innovating is still happening
because i think less of the things that
that spurred on that first
decision any years ago.
Way.
Oh yeah i remember that one but.
The one
that sticks in my mind of for one for one
reason is you are what you eat which i
take a very basic statement of
despite all the intellectual ism.
Ach in terms of whether i can you know
can can sum up some of the insights of
nimbin in a few words it's always hard.
One of the ones that that sticks
in my mind is is one that
when benson used to use
quite a bit which is.
You are what you eat which is on a very
basic statement st spired all the fine
thinking intellectualising
etc.. Basically it's or.
Reduce it all to very simple
things and the other one.
I lost my train of thought for a moment.
There was another one.
The interesting was.
One other sort of if you like slogan i
think they sings are slogans because in a
few words they can't be any
deeper than that one when that
that always stayed with me was. Was that
one of the balinese years which is that.
We have no art we simply do everything
as well as we can and i think
that was to me.
Bit of a statement of the art the artfulness
tore the artless ness of the movement
and made it interesting
musically. Musical phrases.
Always sort of stick with the three years
in the years where no in other things
fired i mean maybe the long
time since i was a particular
that was an im mandela i
guess. Which as you know.
Certainly you know gave me great.
Invigoration and energy at the
time and still that's. Thank you.